the Missouri man hopes to walk out of
prison today after serving nearly two
decades for a murder he did not commit
David Robinson was kept behind bars
even though another man confessed to the
crime back in 2004 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty shows us the
case a judge calls manifest injustice
Erin good morning good morning David
Robinson isn't the only one who says
he's innocent in February a state judge
agreed with him and two weeks ago the
Missouri Supreme Court ordered his
release and yet Robinson remains in
prison which is where we talked to him
last week in a living nightmare it being
an up-and-down roller coaster in 2001
David Robinson was convicted of the
murder of Sheila box a 36 year-old
mother she was found in her car a year
earlier in Sikeston Missouri dead of a
single gunshot wound to the chest I was
in disbelief it changed my world forever
Sheila box's daughter was 17 when she
lost her mom I have memories of dancing
with her in the living room she was
extremely beautiful loving caring police
believed Robinson who had a history of
drug crime shot box during a drug deal
that bothered me more than anything to
be wrongfully accused of killing a woman
but there was little to tie Robinson to
the murder no physical evidence just one
eyewitness Albert Baker a paid police
informant who claimed he saw Robinson
shoot Fox at this busy intersection
filmmakers Steve Turner is working on a
documentary about the case there's no
three or four witnesses who saw him
shoot her there was nothing just one guy
that had a crazy story
there was also an inmate who claimed
that Robinson confessed to him when they
shared a cell charlie weis as Robinson's
attorney turns out he was never in the
same cell David Robinson in the
prosecution put him on the stand even
though they knew he had never shared the
same cell robinson was sentenced to life
without parole but three years later the
case against him fell apart another man
confessed on tape to a defense
investigator that he was the one who
sold drugs to Sheila box and killed her
room Ann's Mosby says he panicked when
he saw she had a gun
in 2009 Mosby took his own life and
Robinson remained in prison even though
by then both witnesses who testified
against him it Bennett they had lied
Albert Baker the paid informant had been
given $2,500 in cash and expenses after
he agreed to testify and still Robinson
remained in prison as appeal after
appeal was denied until last February
when judge Daryl Missy ruled the
evidence clearly shows that David
Robinson did not kill Sheila box the
conviction should be overturned because
the lead detective John Blakely used
unreliable evidence to convict Robinson
and ignored or suppressed facts which
pointed away from him
you're still sitting here how do you
explain that to your family okay I mean
I get asked a question every day my
staff of offenders where they hurt very
tiny asked me even the daughters still
grieving a mother wonders why Robinson
hasn't been released I believe in my
heart that he's innocent and I stand by
him I lend my support to him that's how
it should be the state of Missouri has
until the end of May to either retry
Robinson or free him
what do you want to do when you get out
what's the first thing you want to do my
mother
the Missouri Attorney General is
scheduled to make an announcement later
today now we don't know for sure that
Robinson will be released but the lead
detective resigned last week and with no
evidence remaining it is likely Robinson
will be allowed to finally go home to
hug his mom this is so egregious and I
watched it paid attention closely and I
still don't know why he's still in
prison but it's so I bet the Robinson
family is thanking you Aaron because you
said listen I normally do 48 hours but
this story was so upsetting to me I want
to do this thank you said I can I just
tell you that yes daddy made me promise
that I would say hello to you you have
to say hi there's a quirk in the
Missouri case law if you are facing life
in prison if you're not on death row
actual innocence does not give you a
habeas if you can't prove that you have
a constitutional violation at trial
David Robinson could have spent the rest
of his life in prison even though
everyone knew he was in it but you point
out no physical evidence not in the
victim's family and the guy said a crazy
guy with the story tubes painted one was
paid but both snitches that was it that
was it hopefully he will finally receive
justice today I'm hoping I can't
absolutely say that but I'm hoping but
you're hoping today would be the day I
hope so too and I hope he gets to hug
his mother but what about the decades of
his life that are gone now I don't care
that he's gonna be 51 at the end of this
month he went in when he was 32 yeah
that's a huge part of his life missing
your aunt's hope today's a day